I believe aljo said that in a perfect
world to defend it like once or twice
and then he'll go up
give him Robbie's time and I'll tell you
right now I do believe this and I don't
wanna and I do it I'm not [__] on Vulcan
house he's one of my short bold stocky
hero I like him I like that guy sure so
uh my thing is I feel if aljo had that
bag and I'm and listen it's just like
the way your the shape your body shaped
the bigger arms the bigger guy a guy
with no neck
algae with his arms their wiry I believe
he'll if he doesn't get the neck he'll
break the jaw I believe he gets that
back he's finishing how about that oh no
I agree a fool with you I agree fully
with your matter you know Jiu Jitsu
Brendan you have a smaller wiring guy on
your back get worse than the big mean
heads
uh I mean uh compared to you know we
talk about even technique and skill you
know I would say algae when it comes to
straight Brazilian Jiu Jitsu is way more
versed in that than uh machachev is so
if alja were to get you know
volcanovsi's back that's a long night in
the office for for
that's a winnable fight
now Brandon
what is popping fam is Monday May 29th
it is Memorial Day
um I would say happy Memorial day but if
you know anything about Memorial Day
it's not really a happy day right we're
honoring those that passed away in
combat so uh hope you're having a
good Memorial day but uh the nation got
away from what it really represents it's
to honor those that have fallen in uh
combat so
whole barbecue kind of thing he got out
of hand became like this weird holiday
where people just get out of work and
school but it's really a uh a thank you
yeah that's what it is a tribute to
those that fall in during the time of
war in action so uh shout out to all the
military peeps out there love you guys
uh shout out to my grandpa's freaking
uncles my dad all the military peeps in
my life so uh wouldn't be able to do
this freely if you guys didn't fight for
so love everyone that uh has been in the
military shout out to you guys and
hopefully your day is going okay all
right uh very special episode today we
have the great Ray Longo and Matt Sierra
on the show today not a lot going on in
the fight world as far as fights go but
the whole Real Housewives of UFC drama
you know all that stuff so we got a lot
to talk about those two guys if I could
Bop
bottle up their energy of Matt Sarah and
Ray Longo and put in an energy drink I'd
be a billionaire these boys come in hot
so I'm looking forward to that
conversation as far as Road dates go I'm
in La Jolla this weekend this freaking
Friday Saturday Sunday one show on
Sunday two shows Friday two shows
Saturday one show Sunday
La Jolla Comedy Store is going down one
of my favorite venues in all the land
that is June 2nd through the 4th that's
this week Friday Saturday Sunday La
Jolla comic store come get you some
well let's just jump right on in then
let's Jump Right In with two of the
faces of MMA it is the great Ray Longo
and Matt Sierra enjoy what's going on
fellas
you're on man what's up brother
Brandon what's up man nice to talk to
you dude this might be the first time
I'm on any one of your [__] eight
podcasts
and it Brendan really quick let me let
me tell you about how this thing got
pitched to me ready yeah Longo hey Matt
why didn't want to uh fly us out first
class but they want to put us up into a
hotel and have us do that food truck die
yeah what do you say I go hey man
that sounds pretty [__] cool
and then I get a [__] update
budget cuts man budget cuts no no I got
you somehow no you know you you didn't
get dupe that's the plan to have you
guys out here man that's the plan this
is just this just catching up bro this
isn't the real deal Holyfield man this
is hey man congratulations not you long
ago I'm talking to Brendan
congratulations on everything dude we
hey Brendan we made it you understand
did we there's a lot of casualties in
this game can I do this without looking
at long door I'm looking at one
I want to look at Brendan there's a big
is there any way we can shift this where
I'm looking at everybody
oh chin says no we have to record the
screen
yeah
just pretend um just pretend online can
we just hear his voice
okay all right I'm gonna shut up no
really sir what are you doing now
what am I doing I'm having a good time
you [__] it's Memorial Day no I thought
you was I thought you were sucking on
your thumb I didn't know that's a vape
uh what we're gonna say though Matt
because uh do you do do you ever stop
and smell the roses I don't man I don't
feel like we've made up I'm exhausted
man
well
yes I do I'm not gonna lie to you
somebody once wrote on one of my
comments they are on one of my Instagram
things mad Sarah lives every day like he
just beat GSB I go [__] hey
I could live every day like I just got
back fisted for the third time true
probably seriously Brandon there's a lot
of this cat now the sport being over 30
years old now
we're starting to see some some
casualties some guys that you knew and
you see them at events and you
high-fiving man good to see you how you
been how you feel for the fight
and now all of a sudden they're not
doing so well and you and then so I have
almost like a survivor's kill sometimes
I tell [__] I go long ago a lot of guys
came to the [__] dance after us and
left before us somehow we're still
around yep and uh I I not that it's not
deserving I mean I'm you know I carry my
weight with things but uh
and I don't [__] on anybody I don't
judge anybody but when you're a kid it's
almost like a rock star life and when
you get done and then you got to get a
nine to five you know whatever makes you
happy yeah I I think I think a lot of it
it's just with sports in general it's
you know the UFC takes a lot of heat for
it when guys get done they're like oh
what are they supposed to do now you
know they didn't make enough money to
ride off in the sunset hate to tell you
most sports don't unless you guys are
smart with their money everyone has to
kind of try to figure out what's the
next chapter after whether you know not
compared to the military because
Memorial day but even the military those
guys get done they have a special set of
skills that doesn't really transition
into the real world now some of them do
you know a lot of them know but you know
you look at the jockos and some of those
other guys Tim Kennedys of the world
that came from the military background
and they're massive now in fighting you
know those guys and obviously your your
personality or smart guy and then also
both you guys you know before you came
on Matt I was talking about
it's not how how well you can do it it's
about how long you can do it well and
you guys at uh you know Ray long on
Sears the camp out there you guys have
been doing it long and pretty damn good
for longer than anybody I know and
doesn't look like it's slowing down you
look at your roster and your stable of
Fighters man you guys got something
going on out there
I get Longo before we dive into that I
got I got to point something out to you
guys and
it just hit me thought about this
this is Memorial Day
and I am a big Sylvester Stallone fan I
am it's true from Rocky to Rambo but
let's talk about Rambo for a second this
guy with that speech oh I used to drive
tanks and grow planes and I can't keep
my job [__] cars really are you
[__] special you something's wrong
there there's a guy can't keep a job
parking cars but yeah you can [__]
take out [__] five [__] guys in
the with a [__] knife in the in the
woods and he can [__] build [__]
Forts and [__] he's like he's like
MacGyver before MacGyver but yet he
can't drive a [__] pig can't park a
car well they didn't have podcasting
back then either Rambo could a podcast
no Brenda brings up a good point because
I remember when when Ryan came out of
the Navy he was like what the [__] do I
do now yeah okay like yo you're talking
the elite guys you know the Jocko's and
the Tim Kennedys those guys are special
forces guys they're always going to be
held up on a on a pedestal but you take
the average guy getting off a ship or
coming out of the service they're lost
for the most part they want you know
they just spent four years they they
they're told what to do when they were
going to eat now all of a sudden they're
out it's like the same like you were
saying the same exactly it's a tough
transition but also to correlate that to
the UFC it's like you know Matt Sarah
was a world champion he was a coach on
The Ultimate Fighter like Matt Sarah was
a big deal so it's gonna be easier and
I'm not taking credit away from anything
you've done Matt you're a monster so
Matt's been able to take that and parlay
into what he's doing now the Jesus of
the world you know the the Chuck
liddells of the war back they they were
massive men it's the guys that don't
fight for the title that don't you know
aren't on the pay-per-view when they get
done that's where it gets dicey man yeah
and the sad part would be running into
those guys that didn't even make it to
like the top 15 yes and all they're
talking about when they're 50 is how
they fought the UFC and they can't rub
two nickels together that's a tragedy to
me or or their home minutes at a cardio
kickboxing gym that's why out man yeah
yeah it just kills you because it just
they never let that go and they didn't
never evolved and moved on and tried to
get another skill to to do something but
they're just content with man man I had
a guy remember remember where's uh Matt
I mean yeah I remember he was still
wearing his Golden Gloves that was his
proud I mean which you should be proud
of it but you got to move on if you're
six listen Brendan if you're successful
everything's good once you get that down
you could talk about whatever you want
but if you don't it starts to look bad
yeah well you can't beat Tim Sylvia
wearing that [__] to the [__] club
yeah
that's right he wants belt to that Vegas
club yeah
I got hey hey Brendan Brendan I
guarantee he still didn't get laid
wearing that
uh you know it's kind of like uh Dancing
with the Stars for uh legit actors when
you're going on there you know you're on
the back nine of life now if you're like
if Fighters are doing the slap Fight
League bro you that that's where I'm
like oh bro this is Dancing with the
Stars for Fighters if you're in slap
Fight League it's not good
yeah
hey I disagree I think I think Kim
Sylvia is perfect first lap fight I
think he's I think he's more set for
that than for anything else on this plot
I saw Bigfoot silver Bigfoot Silva once
he involved the slap Fight League I'm
like who the hell is going to take a
slap from Bigfoot Silva now if you if I
would only do it if I get the first slap
because you know he's a little chinny
but if he gets to slap you first he's
going undefeated
yeah that's funny man he's got some he's
got some [__] head on him too oh
giant dick beaters for hands I mean
you're talking about oh [__] yeah yeah
hey back to the the um
the guys when they're done fighting and
whatnot now this is something I would
recommend on a serious note and Longo
knows I've been doing Longo knows me
forever he knows I've been doing this
and you know I felt like I was winning
just when I was able to do
um teach Jiu Jitsu for a living trust me
I am I felt like I could just do this so
I overshot I exceeded my uh expectations
you know but I [__] that up but I you
know I I shot past where I was right um
yeah my goal but my point is when I felt
that was my only like I'll be living off
like at his point I was living off
private lessons and and then I was
teaching a jiu jitsu course at Columbia
University and I was training and taking
some super fights and yada yada this is
my early 20s I'm like look this is what
I'm gonna do let's say I don't make it
to the UFC I don't make it to a big
thing or a big lot of money in fighting
I I I'm not going to have a um a pens a
pension so my two Pizzeria bosses I
remember these two guys Nikki and Louie
over at Pizza Amore they told me when I
was 17. these two twin brothers they
were heavy smoking cigarettes they're
like we'll be doing it to the day we die
you go they go look get mutual funds you
put 200 away every month you don't even
think about it then over 20 years you'll
have something in a and it's stuck with
me and I just was doing that and it
would not even have money does that make
sense yeah like I was I was thinking
like all right just I thought ahead
and Michael knows I'm a [__] so I
thought I knew enough to know that if
this [__] wouldn't work out longer if
this shouldn't work out if this didn't
work out for me I'll have a little
something you know what I mean let's
take a little break from chatting with
Matt Sarah and Ray Longo to my faves
because man the NBA Finals action is
heating up with my friends at DraftKings
sports book my nuggets already in it
baby we swept the freaking Lakers it's
hard to be a nuggets fan when you're in
LA but it is what it is but Miami and
Boston going down game seven is tonight
you need to make some bank with my
friends at DraftKings official Sportsman
partner of the NBA new customers can
place a five dollar bet and score 200 in
bonus bets instantly plus all customers
can take a shot at a bigger payout with
the DraftKings stepped up same game
parlays download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use code shop
show Schaub show new customers can place
a five dollar bet and score two hundred
dollars in bonus bets instantly that's
code shop show only at draftking
Sportsbook bet on my nuggets you don't
think they're gonna sweep the Heat or
the Celtics if you bet on anybody but
the Nuggets don't use my code bet the
Nugget shop show only at DraftKings
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler
Massachusetts call
800-327-5050 or visit
gamblinghelplinema.org in New York call
8778 Hope NY or text Hope and why
467-369 and Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort Kansas Kansas 20 or
older and most eligible States but age
varies by jurisdiction eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
Sportsbook details and state-specific
responsible gambling resources bonus
bets expire seven days after uh
assurance opt-in and 10 plus leg
required for 100 boost eligibility
wagering deposit restrictions apply
terms at Sportsbook Dot draftkings.com
US basketball terms of still listing
download DraftKings promo code shop show
bet on the Nuggets this episode of the
shop show with Ray Longwood Matt Sarah
is brought to you by the best Kratom on
the planet I only recommend products
that I use in this freaking Kratom is
the best you can get the most
trustworthy I use it every single show
that I do with a stand-up or podcasting
it's happy hippo Kratom I love it helps
me tackle whatever busy schedule I got
for the day helps me get stuff done I'm
going to work out right after this
episode and I'm using the happy hippo
Energy Shot I use it non-freaking stop
gives me a good feeling gets my mind
right the Kratom is my Hidden Gem all
you gotta do if you want to try Kratom
whether it's gummies the instant shot
the freaking regular shot the highly
concentrated drops the freaking powders
whatever form you get your kratom in we
got you and it's going to be the best
you've ever tried and they also have the
K dips which is Kratom pouches you know
I like to dip right but now I can dip my
with Kratom it's tobacco nicotine free
it's just kratom in a pouch tastes
delicious I use the blue they have the
winter green they have the blue Razzle I
like both but probably the blue Razzle
have to decide but you're talking about
Kratom pouches first to ever Market
Kratom pouches try it out if you like to
get your Kratom try it the same way you
do your nicotine or however you want to
dip all right and they have it for you
the first ever K dips Kratom pouches are
here go to happyhippo.com promo code is
thick23 thick with three C's 23 and you
save 20 off the entire site including
the K dips including the Kratom uh
energy shots including the happy hippo
instant Kratom gummies whatever you want
your 20 off go to happyhippo.com promo
code is thick 23 20 off you're welcome
now for reals let's get back to the
program I think what's tough because you
know again credit to you guys you guys
look at your roster like Al Joe has his
podcast and he's making good Investments
outside of fighting without it
who opened up the real estate he's
crushing it crushing it crushing it it's
tough because you want to tell those
guys to do that stuff but also in order
to get to where you want to go in
fighting in the UFC especially you can't
be one foot in one foot out so it's this
fine kind of balance that these Fighters
have to do where trust me I'm the first
one to tell you guys start your own
merch do things that you can do where
it's not going to take all your time but
you want to have some sort of plan man
where you're benefiting off your
notoriety right now you don't want to
wait till you're retired but it's tough
because you know a lot of those other
guys aren't doing that all they're
worried about is winning fights man so
it's a fine line you guys seem to figure
it out yeah well look the other thing
too is but I I said this years ago was
more even with Matt wasn't beating GSP
it was the fact he had a great family he
had his businesses those are the things
that I and I really always tried to live
by that by this was like a good coach
can change a fight a great coach can
change your lifetime yeah so I always
kind of wanted to lead by example be
successful myself who the [__] would
listen to me I come driving up in a
[__] 1920s to debate you know what I
mean like and I'm telling everybody what
to do on business yeah you know those
friends and you know those guys are out
there oh yeah like you know I'm from
Missouri I'd rather you know see a
winner watch or win it and listen to one
any day of the week it was it was that
type of mentality so I really feel great
about all of that because all of these
guys are successful 90 of them today are
really successful after fighting and I
think that's a that's a huge huge thing
for me because I feel great about that
and it's what you mean by what is
success I mean like Longo said Brandon
these guys we went to that we went to
the opening of allied with his real
estate uh
um firm firms that we call it real
estate firm yeah yeah yeah yeah uh we
were in his home he opened it up in his
hometown they had a DJ out front his
parents were there the whole fight team
was there I don't know like now look
would we be more happy if he made I
don't millions and this and that I'm not
even saying I would be I don't know like
what why is money the end-all you want
to be set up I'm not against I'm not
hating on money
but I'll tell you right now if I the
ultimate Way of winning the is for me is
the quality of life if I had Millions
a goddamn thing different like today I'm
a little bit late I I tell chin I'm
gonna be running tight because dude I
was at my school why am I at my job on
my day off because it's a [__] good
time correct I don't know what am I
doing I wasn't teaching but I was
hanging out with the guys went over some
[__] Kimora [__] I got this young kid
Tommy who's got a fight coming I don't
know we're having fun
it's not really a job
but man like literally 15 years ago we'd
be hanging out and he's like dude we're
living the dream you know and this was
15 years ago I don't know what we're
living now but if we're living the dream
15 years ago it's a there's a long
really good dream because it never ended
it shows in your Fighters I mean you you
look at you you look at aljo who I think
is the most disrespectful in the UFC for
a number of reasons you know the way he
got the belt and then you know he beat
TJ Dillashaw it's not his fault TJ went
in with one shoulder aljo just did his
job and then you know you look at the
the Henry sahuto fight which I didn't
think was even close
um in any facet
um so I don't know what it's going to
take for aljo to get the the respect and
then you know now you you know they
announced the the sugar Sean fight
happened in August and aljo's like I
didn't agree to that so it just it gets
he gets more disrespect but it doesn't
seem to get to aljo I think again that's
credit to you guys he just he's just
doing his thing man he's just doing it
everywhere a lot of Champions a lot of
guys would be this huge toxic back and
forth and he's like nah man yeah I'll
fight him I'm not 100 but yeah let's do
it you know yeah yeah yeah he sees he's
a little he's pissed he's actually
pissed about that
he's yeah that one actually pissed him
off no I understand he he can be pissed
but I think these guys need to realize
that you know at the end of the day UFC
is a business and you got to do what's
yourself
and when I say pissed I don't mean piss
like us three would be pissed he he's a
thinker Al Joseph think he's he's
thinking pissed he's not like
[__] you know I'm gonna kill
somebody not not that type of pissed
he's just he thinks it out and uh look
he he's surrounded by really good people
he's got great friends he's got a great
family you know the whole thing like uh
well he's you know his girl his grades
going to get married yep uh he's just in
a good spot like I don't think there's
any losing at this I could tell you if I
think the way he's thinking it's he's
already won
side I don't know if he's gonna beat him
with his skill set he's also in a good
position where it's not like all right
well here's this awful match up if you
want to get him out or Dethrone him good
luck good luck yeah well that's what I
love about he goes look man you want to
do this I'm going to show up and piss in
your Cheerios again you're gonna be it's
gonna be worse you're gonna force me to
do something that you think is going to
go one way and it's not and then you're
gonna be even more mad
yeah listen and now just the type of guy
like even when he did an interview and I
can understand if you're promoting a
fight you don't want a guy that's going
to be in the main event or whatever
being like I don't know maybe I think he
you know I'm injured or this I gotta get
killed I feel I think he's so honest
when they ask yeah yes
Sports so you know let me you know I'll
make this happen but let me just you
know nurse this I think he's an honest
guy but I think he had every intention
of fighting but you know listen either
way
I don't think it's a great battle for
sure O'Malley Sean O'Malley's got that
he's very accurate and I think his
grappling is underrated agreed
to the guy and he he took down yon
almost and he's he's not horrible on the
floor but there is levels and I think if
he just needs one takedown one you know
the aljo doesn't even need to take down
there's guys that jump up on backs that
shouldn't jump up on backs yep a lot of
Chris Whiteman Luke rockholden without a
character yeah dude he gets on their
back it's a round winner or a fight
Ender and it could be you know what I
mean so I don't know I think I think
that would that that's what makes aljo
special is he knows where he's special
at now where before it was like man
aljo's good at this he's kind of good at
everything now we know he's in the
outlier like he knows if he gets on your
back this thing's over man
because he really he's too honest he
speaks that's when he's speaking his
mind it's almost like he's thinking as
he's speaking but yeah they did fight
past it uh came in and did like I guess
a special on me that did a some clip so
they wanted to interview Matt nowjo aljo
walks in I look at him I go Joe let me
tell you something lie I don't care
lying is acceptable just [__] lie
don't start thinking about don't
overthink what's going on I I didn't
even give a [__] I go you I want to lie
forget about it he'll start breaking it
then yeah I don't know he was wasn't
looking so good one
you can't and I love them but I go and
he's laughing because he knows I go just
[__] lie more Sports more Sports
could use that Honesty like that's one
of the reasons that I see so big because
you tune in the NFL NBA and it's just
you're just getting these cookie cutter
answers like nah man talk a little smack
be honest with this yeah just be honest
and that's why again that's why I think
aljo should have more support he's he's
yeah you know the USA slogan as real as
it is what about Francis leaving and he
was fighting for every fighter in the
UFC to get more why are people not
reason this guy up on their shoulders
and Guy Francis thanks he took the head
he's almost like
yeah I'm not going to kick him the
current flood back in the you know with
the baseball when they unionized but he
really I it appeared was looking out for
everybody I think it's crazy the friend
the friend yeah I the the hate Francis
got for that is ridiculous because he's
just doing what he thought was best for
himself I actually side with Dana on
this where
again I love Francis he's on the show a
million times I absolutely love Francis
good for him for getting that pfl deal
but I side with Dana on this side when
it comes to business because you're
looking at a guy who's 36 years old
coming off a knee injury he's not that
active he's never been a big
pay-per-view star he's asking for all
this crazy demands and Dana goes we're
good we're good man we're going to give
you the big the big money fight Jon
Jones we know that's going to go well
but after that we we can't justify
paying you that much money to fight a
pavlovich or a Curtis blades again or
aspin all because that's probably not
going to do well we're going based off
these numbers over here so we're good to
let you go man people are upset about
that but if I'm Dana I don't know if I
do it any different I gotta be honest
I'm not [__] on at all I like
Francis too he seems like a nice guy but
hey man that's Cheryl gone fight
you know zero gone
it just made a lunk head [__]
decision to lay down with a tree trunk
of a leg he got the single leg he got to
the fifth round without taking much
damage at all he goes for a takedown
between the fourth and fifth round let's
put it this way we needed the fifth
round they both needed the fifth round
so what happens who made that [__]
correction for that fifth round to win
it spirogon did he got him down without
taking a boom single leg I believe it
was and then he [__] lays down with a
leg like oh I don't know what he was
thinking but that caused him to fight it
was his bad not Francis is good yeah
basically followed him on top you know
what I mean so I don't know man it's not
like yo he showed the champion he is in
that fifth round and he he weathered it
he got him now he's [__] played off
this dude's mistake I'm just calling it
how I see it this is exactly how it
happened
yeah I think too with with the Francis
thing I hope it works out for him I I'd
be curious if going into negotiations
with Dana if someone went up to Francis
went hey man that Tyson Fury fight ain't
happening so whatever Hill you're gonna
die on in here the chance of that Fury
fight happen is not good you're gonna
end up signing with another MMA
organization I don't know if he makes
the same decision you know because it
doesn't look like we're gonna hit that
Fury fight so I think the verdict's
still out on France if he made the right
choice I know he's going for a fighter
rights and equal pay and all that stuff
I just don't know if he was the guy to
do it to make the change I like that he
had the message I don't know if he was
the guy to do it but we'll find out if
Francis made the right choice probably
in a year from now we'll see how this
pfl goes just look at the pfl I think
Francis got a great deal the pfl is
going to have a hell of a time trying to
get their money out of that
yeah no at that point I definitely agree
with but again knowing where Francis
came from again I think it's already a
win for him agree and you know and and
you know friends and everybody I'm gonna
do what's right for me I I like that but
if everybody does what's right for them
trust me nothing's ever going to get
done you know what I mean like if I'm
going in today what's right for me might
be to spend you know have dinner with my
family but a guy's got a fight coming up
so I'm not going to do what's right for
me I'm gonna do what's right for
whatever goal I think I'm attaining and
that could be wrong but uh
that thing always kills me I'm gonna do
what's right for me yeah
if I would have did what's right for me
I would have got rid of you four years
ago
if you do what's right for you I mean
even look at aljo and Murad marab's like
we're not fighting each other it's not
happening now what's the the smart
business thing to do probably fighting
each other for the time there's no
question about that no question about it
we get that I get that for sure but I
don't know it's the right thing to do
for Al Joe you know I would assume the
plan beat sugar Sean then go up to 45
and let marab you know do his thing at
35. that that's probably the best move
for both parties I I would think that
that would be the likely scenario quick
little break then we'll jump right back
into the convo with Matt Sarah and Ray
Longo because this episode of the shop
show is brought to you by on it the one
and only the best nootropic on the
planet talking about Alpha Brain now
you've heard of Alpha Brain they've sold
over a million bottles you can try it
out risk-free because you don't love it
they give you your money back you don't
have to return the Alpha Brain keep the
brain share it with a friend but they
return your money no questions asked we
got you covered man they have the
regular Alpha Brain but they have more
than that they have Alpha Brain Black
the highly concentrated Alpha Brain they
have a instant Alpha Brain the shots you
get eight ounces of water put a little
of the Alpha Brain in there you're ready
to go everyone get your nootropic this
is the best time to do it with on it
because you save 10 off by using the
promo code shop go to audit.com job you
save 10 off all the Alpha Brain instant
Black Label regular Alpha Brain they've
sold over a million bottles of the best
nootropic on the planet you gotta get
your mind right with Alpha Brain it aids
and mental processing it's caffeine free
helps you get in the low State support
your memory helps you remember names
which I could definitely use some of
these dagestanian Fighters and Brazilian
Fighters focus on complex tasks think
more clearly under stress react more
quickly they got it all for you go to
audit.com you receive 10 off all the
Alpha Brain
and if you don't love it you get your
money back what do you have to lose
anna.com shop 10 off you're welcome
I believe aljo said that in a perfect
world to defend it like once or twice
and then it'll go up
give him Robbie's time and I'll tell you
right now I do believe this and I don't
wanna and I do it I'm not [__] on
vulcanowski he's one of my short bold
stocky hero I like him I like that guy
sure
my thing is I feel if aljo had that back
and I'm and listen it's just like the
way your the shape your body shaped the
bigger arms the bigger guy a guy with no
neck
Al Joe with his arms their wiry I
believe he'll if he doesn't get the neck
he'll break the jaw I believe he gets
that back he's finishing how about that
oh no I agree a fool with you I agree
fully with your man you know Jiu Jitsu
Brendan you have a smaller wiring guy on
your back they're worse than the big
Meat Heads
uh I mean uh compared to you know we
talk about even technique and skill you
know I would say algae when it comes to
straight Brazil in Jiu Jitsu is way more
verse than that than uh machachev is so
if alja were to get you know
volcanovski's back that's a long night
in the office for for
that's a winnable fight yeah I love that
fight I like bogonowski a lot how you
guys you guys think your boy Matt uh the
steamroller is going to get that fight
with Patty boy is he vying for it man he
he hasn't Steve I have to tell him not
even to mention in the gym anymore he
just doesn't stop he does just doesn't
stop and every time I think I get him to
stop he waits a week and a half he comes
back in guns blazing again he's really
Maddie's really he's one of those guys
that I don't know maybe because
he's not as I don't think he's not
horrible in front of the mic or anything
but I think I don't know what it is but
man every one of his fights are like oh
yeah fighting as [__]
three first round knockouts the exact
reason not three Knockouts 10 seconds
will be three first round knock oh no
he's crouching right now I mean people
love the guy we just can he give him in
front of more people yeah and we had him
on the week the Monday before his fight
with Drew Dober and Drew dober's from my
neck of the woods he drew Dover is a
mother man and I told Maddie I said
Daddy I know you like this you know
throw those things in there and go for
The Knockout yes and I said I'm sure Ray
and Matt are telling you this fight you
win it here buddy you can't go in there
and just you know aim for that chin like
this this has to be one of those fights
you got to show in order to get to the
top 15 it's not it's not about going in
there playing Rock 'em sock'em to begin
the top 13 it's here now bud oh boy did
he do it yeah he did and I'll tell you I
remember even like when I was in that
Rogan goes that was a you that's a huge
win I go that is a hundred percent a
huge win I really we I can't tell you
the respect I got for Drew Dover you
know and I I was worried going into that
fight too I mean I thought we had a
great game plan taking away his left
hand but hey still he's still the guy's
got to do it but dope is a ma I think
he's a monster that was a dog that was a
dog going into that fight too
yo a pretty sizable dog too
we didn't get to see it and I'm not
giving away [__] for the future too much
because he's used it in the past versus
the tarantula
nice so we didn't get to see him now I'm
glad we didn't get to see it because
he's got a lot more tools and he was
blending it nice Mariah by the shots to
the strikes and yeah so yeah but I'm
guessing but it never got to that point
but because he has that power and the
way he Blends in the takedowns in a
longer fight he's he's a he's really uh
more more of a threat than than people
think yeah these get better and better
on the floor he he rolls down I would
assume chain with those monsters with
marab and alja I assume his ground game
is pretty damn good have to be but I
with I'm curious if the UFC does do that
the the Patty vs uh Maddie fight I'm
curious if they actually do that because
you look at that fight on paper and
listen I I I I love Patty Patty's a
great kid tough fight for Patty man you
know he he'd be a dog in that fight
yeah
yeah I agree with you in a weird
position because he's coming off a win
that everybody feels it's a loss and you
know what I mean so it's like and and
you can tell
as a guy that does he have any losses
I'm not in the UFC but
does he have losses in general I think
Patty has he had one last thing uh in uh
cage Warriors
yeah the way he handled it and I'm not I
like that he's a nice kid great kid he's
fresh meatball mechanic yeah you know
Molly you know they're they're cool
but you could tell it hurt him that
people were saying he lost like he
didn't had a at first he was doubling
down on he won then oh we could fight
again and then it's like yo man just
keep keep winning kid don't worry that
you win or lose or close fight they're
gonna talk [__] correct you don't you're
dwelling on that [__] why are you
calling to fight the guy again to show
people I mean I don't know I know he's a
young kid too and when I was younger I
was way more off the handle so I get it
but but yeah we didn't we didn't have to
deal with social media different animal
now man these kids get on there and
they're getting every comment every slap
Dick and Harry given their opinion and
these kids are reading those comments
and it botherism trust me hip-hop take
time I mean with Patty he said the thing
that got to him is he was okay with
accepting he's gonna move on and then
when he heard Rogan go on his podcast
like you know Patty not when that fight
said that's the one that got him you
know because Rogan has a lot of power
when Rogan says you never win that fight
MMA goes you didn't win that fight
right right right yep yeah well that's
Rogan's opinion for sure man I mean you
know I mean everybody's got their own so
I mean you don't want to lie about it
and I don't know I remember definitely
feeling he didn't win it but
I've seen worse decisions too so that
was my take exactly man I I've seen way
worse decisions even who can't beat this
kid up over it he did his best judges
gave to move on man I've seen way behind
robberies you know you know what the
problem too is it's almost like you go
in with some sort of confirmation bias
you don't like them yeah and if you
don't like them then you just you you're
just he lost yep for sure I I do think
he lost but I think that adds to a tune
plus we love Jared Gordon so I I'm the
first guy to say I'm biased I'm going to
say one problem I'd be the worst either
way you know what I mean but uh Jared's
a great kid and Patty's you know a
little Brash so you want to see those
guys humbled a little bit and I think
that's part of the problem too is that
people are gonna that that's the
direction they go in yeah if you can get
all that attention I think for Patty
Kenny be a world champion sure is he
there yet in top 15 no but you know his
stardom has surpassed his skill level
right now so there's gonna be a lot of
hate and sugar was that guy for a little
bit but now when sugar beat Peter yawn
he kind of Justified himself getting all
that attention Patty hasn't got that big
win yet he's just not there well but
plus sugar if you look at him he's got
great movement in his face a great he
could box oh yeah he looks totally
different and Patty's wild he's wide but
he doesn't he's not doesn't look like a
a seasoned Pro by no means and and sugar
really does though he really he looks
good whether he's going to be durable
enough to to go to Long Haul that's a
big factor I think but from the outside
looking in he's dangerous for sure from
the outside and that was a fight with
Yan where I was okay with that decision
where everybody everybody thought that I
mean the majority of people seem to
think the young one I was definitely
okay but I thought it was I remember
thinking that O'Malley won then I heard
the bad blood it's like oh okay
yeah same thing not a robbery close
close fight yeah yes sugar
won the fight no but nobody got screwed
I was surprised I think again like what
you said about Rogan they see a
backstage of Habib going oh I can't
believe it so they're like oh look yeah
so you know I don't know I I thought
that was way closer than people gave
Sean O'Malley credit for now now Matt
like me you're you're tough alumni and
The Ultimate Fighter is kind of making a
a comeback now it's been it's been dark
days for ultimate fire there's about
seven people watching the past about 10
years since we left my man but now it's
back on mainstream TV it's back on
regular ESPN you got Conor McGregor
Michael Chandler you uh you excited for
The Ultimate Fighter kind of making a
Resurgence here
well listen this is what I'm excited
about for that show is the participants
I mean yeah right now I don't know your
case Brendan but that changed my life
about that long ago it'll be attest to
that again mine was kind of a special I
mean anybody it's a gateway to the UFC
that show alone it showcases your
personality yes and it showcases who you
are when I went on that season of The
Ultimate Fighter the comeback I didn't
look at the prize at the end of it or
this and I just looked at it like look
fight at a time look at it like a
training camp if worst case scenario
people get to see me on it maybe they'll
like me maybe I'll get a few more
students from my school which I enjoy
doing so I didn't look that's how I
looked at it but it did it changed my
[__] life me too it came you know so
it's the reason my wife didn't have to
become a schoolteacher and uh so all
right Londo remember that [__] yeah yeah
and it led to that my thing was the
title shot thing so I think the
opportunity it gives for people is
is amazing
Brandon he he's saying a thing with the
personality which is probably
true but the phone call was we got one
last shot we got to do this I mean if
you think about that was it we were
focused on winning that that thing 100
he goes listen there's not going to be
another shot I just got this call can we
do this blah blah blah blah blah that
was it it wasn't you know I'll let my
personality shine through which
obviously it did I think that show is
what ruined them because he went [__]
berserking he found out people like this
personality they haven't even got work
printed he got worse double down I'm
trying to pinpoint the the time that he
just lost his [__] and I'm coming up
with that show that's all that comes up
in my mind [__] I I used to hide my
comic books when you'd walk in the room
and I was like now I just flaunt I tell
people I know I just as you get older
you give less of a [__] I agree
Brandon I'd walk into the room and I I
I'd see a comic book on his end table
I'm like you know just like I say like
you know what tell the story like you
know so and so did this I know I had a
fighter that thing made me question
everything I was like this [__]
The Ultimate Fighter was uh especially
back in the day especially your season
my season it was a big deal man and then
for the past couple of years you know I
don't manage Fighters but if I would I'd
be curious your guys thoughts on this I
was always under the assumption if I had
a fighter young fighter trying to get in
the UFC I'll put them on Dana White's
Contender series I think that's put out
the best prospects ever besides Ultimate
Fighter back in the day now if I had a
fighter I would not this season but in
the past I would say go on Dana White
Contender series instead of doing
ultimate fighter nobody's watching
Ultimate Fighter do Dana White Contender
series but now with the Conor and the
Chandler maybe now is the time to go
back to a fighter well we'll find we'll
find out but that Contender series
honestly is no joke you're getting
matched up those are tough those fights
man listen guys don't sleep on Dana
while you're looking for a fight what's
the matter with you oh [__] as far as
finding Talent come on man where'd you
think you found Jared Gordon the back
alley beating someone up no man but in a
while looking for a fight Dana doing
away looking for a fight and you're on
that right Matt listen to be transparent
I've I've never seen it I do so many
shows myself I haven't seen it but is
that a show where he he goes to an uh a
fight and they're just looking for
talent and then does he put the talent
on Dana White Contender series or that's
separate it they some guys now look the
show's been around forever it's been
around 10 years you don't have to you
don't have to like Dana to watch to
enjoy that show Brenda hey Matt I'm not
bringing up nothing
I'm friendly with you my friend so I'm
not bringing up no [__] no there's
no [__] here no bad hold up Matt
there's no there's no [__] we had I
have no no issues with Dana man everyone
thinks I hate the guy my entire business
model is based off his business I have
no issues with the guy I'm just saying
I've never seen that show I loved I
think Dana White Contender series is the
best fight product you know the UFC's
put out I think the con you look at the
contenders and UFC now like that kind of
feeder league is brilliant I prefer that
to The Ultimate Fighter that's true but
like you said you have not seen Dana
White looking yeah he just hey hey hold
on you're ready long though Brandon you
don't think I tried my [__] hand that
[__] hey Phil the burner guy go [__]
yourself I'm doing a podcast sorry this
is
Brandon you don't think I tried my hand
at [__] comedy as as Brian Kailyn I
went to the Laugh Factory this is what
we do I heard right listen I swear I
swear to God
looking for a fight right what we do is
we look we go to either these towns
whatever [__] state or account we
went to Mexico one time we go to these
smaller events looking for talent and
while we're in that town we do some
wacky [__] I wrote a [__] ball not
even not no [__] like some jackass
[__] Dana listen long ago you got to
give him credit for this the guy jumped
on a bowl when he was 50 something years
old
now listen so when we so we do swacky
[__] do we did one in L.A we finished
visited the big donut shop we made some
donuts and then myself Dean Thomas and
Dana in a spot at the Laugh Factory
Brian Carolyn I when I got up to relate
to this after your first time doing
comedy didn't it feel like an adrenaline
like and I'm not doing it anymore
because it's not my thing but but after
I felt like I want to fight you get like
an adrenaline rush no oh yeah
are you regret Brendan are you
regretting this interview no I love it
okay I love it man you know it's
Memorial Day I love it man
Friday
afterwards like Brian they got it on and
I went to give him a kiss but I think we
invite we kind of we went to get a cheek
but I kind of got his mouth a little oh
yeah that's right he's a full-blown gay
man no Brian trying to suck you man
you're lucky you didn't pull your pants
down but how how did uh Thomas and Dana
do at the Laugh Factory now Dana oh
listen Thomas did good he used a crutch
at the time he threw out the n word
I couldn't do that
I could such a crutch such a crutch
Thomas I'm not bullshitting you man you
know he stopped it it was it was but it
was funny he's Dean Thomas has about as
many jobs as you Brandon he's a [__]
guy that's just he's a very good man
yeah I love that guy he's a talented guy
he's a funny man and I'm lucky that I
get paid to hang out with that guy it's
really fun and Dana Dana had Tony
Hinchcliffe we didn't know this he
[__] us with this he said it on the
episode
but this episode it was supposed to be
the tooth the tooth got kicked off right
before this we left or whatever so Dean
came in on two days notice and stepped
up to the plate but David's way of
thinking was he's gonna book this thing
he thought I'd land on my feet because
I'm a naturally silly guy he thought
tooth was gonna get [__] because the
tooth is kind of and then he had
something prepared he was getting
personal [__] lessons from Tony
hinckliff he was so he had all yeah
Tony's a roast writer he does he killed
Tony's show he's he's very close to the
road like he brought in a Savage to help
him out there yeah yeah those guys are
good man it's a big difference when you
get a professional race [__]
hey I wrote my one I only have one bit
it was a rocky bit and I and that was my
only thing I had and it [__] killed
I'm not listening there was a UFC crowd
I'm not on my break but I am breaking a
little but they did like it and [__]
uh and Tony hinklers gave me a
compliment you know I made me happy he
doesn't give a lot of those out he
doesn't give a lot of those out so that
means a lot
dude I'll ask him if he might have been
just bullshitting me no yeah he liked it
so that made me happy man so yeah the
show's been going on for 10 years and
you shoot like in three months or you do
it year round is there off season what's
going on I'll tell you when I shoot
Brandon I get a phone call or a text we
got this date we're gonna be over in uh
[__] [__] Missouri on Vancouver
like all right I sometimes I don't even
know anything else in that [__] it and
then we so it's very
it's very uh just organic you know what
I mean we meet up I know we're gonna
have a good time because I get along
with Dane I get along with Dean
dude it's a fun it's just my my secret
to success personally okay Longbow write
this down no it's never too late my
secret to success is if I'm having fun
whether it's my podcast UFC unfiltered
with Jimmy Norton
I love Jimmy I love Jimmy my little bird
or what I do with Dana Dana White
looking for a fight or when I'm at my
school's [__] seven days a week
teaching Jiu Jitsu and having a good
time but I'm having a good time
generally everybody's kind of having a
good time yeah you know what I mean
that's just that's all it is if I'm not
having fun no one's having fun that's
how I look at it so is that what wait is
that what you want me to write down
let me ask you something let's test the
theory out now are you having a good
time now
because I'm having a shitty time
that thing I wouldn't write that down if
my life
when people watch Dana White look inside
these things
I'm not playing peekaboo
Brendan how about this you've seen Step
Brothers oh yeah what is the best part
of that [__] movie The outtakes yes
when you see them dying trying to get
through the scene yeah you know they're
really having fun I don't know no I dig
it man I'm with you brother did people
get they Vibe they get the Vibes if
you're having fun what you and Brian
Kailyn yeah I refuse to correct you
correct his last name's Callum but I I'm
gonna do the fine kid after this I'm
gonna keep telling me call him Kailyn
I'm just gonna run okay
Brandon to be awesome
Fighters by the first names I don't know
his last name maraba I don't know his
last name refuse to attempt it yeah yeah
right you want to laugh I know Brian
what'd you say Caitlyn I'm calling him
Cowan anyway I know Brian catlin's just
the 90s bro when he was on Mid TV yeah
he was trading at Enzo yep I believe he
got his blue belt there when I was there
so I remember him I mean I know Brian
for a long time
you know he's always been a [__] good
dude oh yeah he's the best I think he's
a great that guy loved that guy he's a
great guy no he's the best you know I
went to see his comedy act in Jersey
probably a couple of months ago I don't
know maybe a half a year ago you told me
that I saw your friend and I was worried
like what do you uh I haven't been to a
comedy club in years I didn't stop
laughing yeah it was an hour straight
that guy was really he thought he's
really good yeah Town's a b speaking
speaking of good guys what's Weidman up
to is he is he making a comeback
yeah he does he's looking for an
opponent now oh damn leg's good to go
and he he's he's back up again yeah I
heard he's kicking he told me he's
kicking like a mule worse than I guess
his leg is stronger than ever but that's
what he's saying and I talk to people uh
down in uh Carolina where he is they
said no he's just but he's still killing
the room so he's uh I just got off the
phone and maybe a couple of days ago
he's definitely uh
he's in Pursuit looking at maybe August
or September damn and he's maybe to put
him on that boxing card and he's also
he's he got into podcasting too right
he's yeah
I think so yeah yeah I've done it a
couple of times but he's had a couple of
different podcasts like believe unless
Sirius picked up the other one but
yeah that part it's hard to keep up with
everybody Brendan everybody's all over
the place oh nice it was nice when Al
Joe's fight we all went out to dinner
yeah yeah it was great you know because
we haven't seen him as much because they
went to South Carolina he would you know
so you know I haven't seen his son in so
long too CJ Olson he's up to you it's
just it's strange because we know these
guys when they didn't have kids so it's
cute like the circle of life thing
how old are your kids Matt
Ronaldo's about to call me the uh F-word
logo
about my family
I'm very sensitive as he got older very
soon that's how it goes man he's a human
being at this point he's crying during
movies he can't even look at him the
wrong way he'll stop that's kids Man
kids all crying at any given second 100
percent
there's a yeah there's a Machine Gun
Kelly song that's got me it's the one
he's so I forgot what it's called I'm
serious about him talking to his
daughter when he's gone oh I know what
you're talking about yeah he writes her
a letter basically yeah and then I can't
make it through but I'm driving I go
this is such a good song let me make it
through and then
I can't [__] do it and I thought you
know I gotta get back to my Tahoe long
ago
I don't like being face to face it's not
funny seeing a bald man crying traffic
and how old are the kids
my kids are 14 12 and 10 in a couple of
weeks oh damn and they're eight they're
all doing a jiu-jitsu tournament soon
that's good okay my wife too yeah the
old train they all train
I love it man I love it yeah it's so
much he calls me one day Brandon goes is
this normal I'm crying during a movie so
I go dude I go 100 I gotta be crying for
the last 10 years at this point I don't
know when it happens but when it happens
There's No Going Back you just start
balling at everything yeah man once you
have kids it's just like the life life
is scary and more fragile and dude yeah
I'll cry yeah whatever doubt yeah man I
went to Little Mermaid yesterday my kids
I wanted to freaking cry because I was
in Little Mermaid but um yeah no you'll
just start crying man it is what it is
yeah God forbid that mermaid gets hurt
that's it's over
well Phillips I know you guys got a busy
day man I could talk to you guys for
freaking hours I'm telling you nothing
Matt I'm telling you Ray was right next
time I see you guys can be in person
it's gonna be in person we'll get you
out here you know I don't know if I give
you the same treatment as looking for a
fighter with Dana I don't have Dana
money but it'd be a good time well
listen how about this watch the LA
episode could you just do that you don't
like that if you do you don't hit the
fold it right past him and get the name
no I mean you're my word I'll watch it
I'm gonna start watching it I need a new
show to watch I'm gonna start watching
you got my word hey you know what's
funny and I'm not starting to Feud up
but I'm not starting a feud with you and
that area
that La episode because during now
listen I I had a little bit more time
before the [__] light went on so I
got done with my little bit and I go
look and this is exactly when Dana threw
out um he threw him out during that
Brock Lesnar yeah so did he that
happened like that the day off or some
[__] so it was a UFC crowd so I go look
now date is coming up next and if
anybody had those in he'll throw you out
of here fasting and he [__] threw out
every whole audience I kind of did a
little thing there and it went over
better than that but it was [__] and
it was since that Ariel I was I don't
know we didn't get along too well yeah
sensitive guys did I get it man you know
it's the business way and I get it
you know what's funny though nowadays is
is that you could have like a little
[__] guy like that talk this [__]
like to you and really be like I'm gonna
dig in on bread and because he knows it
because good listen we're all civilized
human beings he knows you're not gonna
get him and smack him and just make him
cry it's not gonna be like you can't do
that now I can't do it there's too many
cameras there's lawyers so when people
like so like like a Leafly guy when a
Weasley guy knows I had Henry shahudo's
coach that little [__] with the
glasses that little coach piggy I coach
coach what's his name coach Piggy
Captain cow with Eric that little [__]
hey I heard it
now we're fighting my days are fighting
are over I know I still got [__] ass
oh damn
thank you Brandon but listen
my point is this
guy somebody told me this thing on Ariel
wani he's like got all [__] written down
like shahudo does and like
who don't want to talk [__] about people
and he's fighting them why is that
little fat [__] [__] hitting behind you
and he's nice to me in person that goofy
little [__] why are you talking about me
and he goes he goes Ray Longo he's doing
a little he goes he's quoting little
things about each guy and Matt Sarah a
hundred pounds heavier than when you
fought GSB and he goes and you say
you're not short you you're stocky you
are short hey dude who the [__] are you
talking to you little [__] we're not
supposed to we're not fighting you
little [__] why are you talking about me
that's the business you're living man
sounds like he needs Tony Hinchcliffe to
punch up some of his [__] talking right
did I just like to have a [__] good
time man me too brother you guys are the
best time next time I see this in person
yeah I appreciate you guys man thanks
Ray Matt love you guys man
thanks Brendan thank you fellas all
right that's it guys hope you guys
enjoyed the very entertaining Matt Sarah
and Ray Longo to my faves to my phase
one on the show for a while next time
you see them to be here for he either a
food truck or fight companion in person
it's been a grand old time uh I'll be on
the road this week kind of I don't have
to take a plane I get to drive to San
Diego La Jolla Comedy Store is this
Friday Saturday Sunday it's at The
Comedy Store my favorite venues and all
the land that's two shows Friday two
shows Saturday one show Sunday do I'm
working on the Lord's day Sunday one
show only at 7 p.m but two shows Friday
seven and nine thirty two shows Saturday
seven and nine thirty then one show on
Sunday at 7 p.m that's in La Jolla right
outside San Diego The Comedy Store
tickets at thickboy.com hope you guys
enjoyed the episode with Ray and Matt
love you guys be safe enjoy your
Memorial day I'll see you around